congratulations everybody this movie is
the best of the worst
yay i'm so i'm so proud of you guys
the best of the worst it's fantastic
[Music]
okay star wars the revenge of the sith
yep the sith are getting their revenge
in this one that's sure for true
now this prequel trilogy for the most
part has been pretty bad
this movie is definitely a step up from
the other two it's definitely like in
this one they were like okay let's
actually try and get it together a
little bit and tell like more of a solid
story
but it still suffers from a few of the
same problems
as the other two films but it's just
better done
alright so let's go over what happens in
this movie so we've got obi-wan kenobi
and anakin skywalker they're going to
rescue
chancellor palpatine from this guy named
general grievous who looks really cool
honestly and i hear he's in the video
games or something
because he's a really cool looking
character the way he moves and he's a
cyborg apparently
so this guy's got general grievous and
he ends up escaping
but in the scene the important thing
that happens is anakin
ends up totally killing count dooku so
it reminded me
a lot it was actually a replay of that
scene between palpatine
vader and luke in return of the jedi
when palpatine is urging luke do it do
it
use the force uh let your hate flow
through you and all that it's the same
exact thing
except anakin obviously was unable
to overcome his emotions and he just
kind of gave into his emotions and
he was manipulated by palpatine's
treachery
so he kills count dooku and he's just a
step further
on to the dark side so padme also
returns in this movie
but this version of padme i have a bone
to pick with so in the other two movies
she was badass she was fighting she had
a gun she was doing her thing
both those movies she was doing cool
stuff she wasn't just sitting around all
day
and i was excited about that i was like
she's not just a damsel but in this one
this character is completely different
so the first time we see her she's like
i'm pregnant and that's her role for the
rest of the movie she's a hotel lady
she's she's sitting in hotel rooms
crying
being all like anakin oh i love you so
much she's not even speaking
the same she's not even the same
character that was very very annoying
i'm not sure what happened with this
character it's like this character had a
little bit of depth
in the first two movies and then now
she's just
a side character she's just literally
anakin's girlfriend and that's kind of
not cool
it's kind of a complete waste of this
character and of natalie portman
and that really really is a shame if
this character had been better this
movie would have been
a lot better i think and can i just say
her death was really silly i haven't
gotten to that yet but her death was
just
made no sense it was really silly but
anyway anakin
starts having visions about her dying in
childbirth
right sound familiar sounds familiar to
me that's right out of doom messiah
people get mad at me when i say that
star wars is ripping from dune but
that's right out of doom messiah and
then what happens at the end with the
twins
right out of doom aside he's like having
visions about her dying in childbirth
and then she dials it dies
and childbirth and gives birth to
surprise twins that's
exactly like dude messiah but anyway
so anakin is getting closer and closer
to palpatine but the jedi won't make
anakin a full jedi yet they kind of
don't
trust him just for some reason but
anyway chancellor palpatine was like you
know what screwed you guys
anakin gets to be on the jedi council
council and he is
my representative on the jedi council
and so
the jedi kind of pissed off about this
they're like okay anakin you can be on
the jedi council or whatever but you
gotta spy
on palpatine for us and this makes
anakin like not really trust the jedi
either
so here's the thing there's weirdness
with the jedi like their whole
bureaucracy system is kind of weird how
they say they're like not a part of the
government but they are
a part of the government it's like their
whole thing is weird so i get
why anakin was kind of like hey you guys
kind of suck too but also anakin like
open your eyes palpatine is like not a
good guy listen to this advice
none of this is good but anyway
palpatine is able to manipulate anakin
because he knows the anakin
is having visions about padme dying in
childbirth and
he's talking all of this stuff about how
he knows
how to prevent people from dying it's a
part of
a different side of the force that he
can tap into called the dark side
and he tempts anakin by telling him that
he knows he knows about the dark side
and he can teach anakin how to use it
and he can have the power to save
admit i will say this anakin isn't a
total dimwit because he's not fully
convinced
immediately he knows there's something
up so he
kind of figures out i guess that
palpatine is like a sith lord and he's
responsible for this whole
droid war that's popped off suddenly
so he informs samuel jackson
uh mace windu i think is the character's
name he's like samuel this guy
he's he's sith and so mace window he
confronts
palpatine he almost kills this dude i
was like yes kill him but i knew he
wasn't going to kill him because i know
this is pretty cool and this guy's
in the original one so i knew something
was going to happen but then anakin
even though he turned the guy in he he
betrays
samuel l jackson and attacks his fellow
jedi for this clearly evil guy
and then pledges himself to the sith and
i was like what
i'm like what that was that was stupid i
was so pissed off at anakin i don't feel
like his action was really justified
i'm like why did you you know he started
this war you know he's a sith lord
you you turned him in the mace windu
what do you think mace windu is going to
do just let him live
like that was so dumb i don't get it and
then after that anakin is just
full on he he goes he it it's a complete
shift from that point on
he's full-on evil and he kills children
he just goes in and kills a bunch of
children and from that point on i was
like no
i i can't possibly root for this
character i'm not supposed to root for
this character anymore that's obvious
but also the thing is it was kind of
heavy-handed it's kind of
heavy-handed how they have to like
show them we have to see him kill kids
well we don't see it but he has to kill
kids for us to be like okay now he's bad
i feel like there are subtle more subtle
ways to do this there's more subtle ways
to take a character from
no good innocent to bad i feel like in
this movie the shift
is just a little bit too sudden and i
know you might come in and say well you
know
palpatine has been coaching him this
entire time and putting little things in
his head
but ultimately anakin still knew right
from wrong up until that point because
he turned palpatine in
so if he didn't know what palpatine had
done up to this point was wrong why
would he even turn him in
so does it make sense for anakin to make
that ship so suddenly
and basically condemn may swindu to
death i guess he's dead
but as i figured out this point that
anytime somebody falls off of something
in star wars
and we don't see their mangled body
they're gonna show up again so he's
probably not dead he probably shows up
in like a book or video game or
something i don't know
but for him to go from that to just
killing children was
insane to me insane to me and so
natalie portman's character finds out
about what he's done and she's like oh
no
there's there's still good in him
somehow
and i don't understand how she can be
like they're still good in him
he killed children once you kill a group
of children that's kind of irredeemable
i get that they're trying to make a call
back to the original
trilogy when lucas like i know they're
still good in him but i'm sorry that
does not work in this movie when i just
saw him kill a bunch of kids i i'm not i
don't
need to think about i'm not trying to
think about someone being a good person
after you just kill a room full of like
12
kids or something you know i don't wanna
they're not a good person no there's no
good in that
so while anakin is killing all the kids
palpatine executes order 66
which i guess was meant to be the this
battle station is fully operational
moment from you know return of the jedi
but this time
i think this is from what i can gather
this killing of all this of all the jedi
is a big event in star wars history this
is a big moment
and it seems like it kind of happened it
happens in a montage here
which is a little weird i gotta say i
feel like
a lot of this movie was fluff and i wish
that part of it could have been
stretched out that part of it
the jedi being hunted down and killed
could have been a whole movie
and i i don't i don't i don't yeah it
could have been an entire
long thing so i don't understand why it
happens in a montage that's a little
weird
but the idea of like that happening in
the clone suddenly activating and
turning on all the jedi that's super
cool
um but the way it happens so like it's
kind of like
it just feels like kind of sloppy and
kind of rushed
so like i said good idea kind of sloppy
kind of
kind of rush and that's kind of the
theme for this movie in my opinion
there's some good ideas and concepts
some of them borrowed from other places
but
it's kind of sloppily done
and so at the climax of this movie
we've got obi-wan we've got padme and
we've got
anakin they're on a volcano planet
and anakin is just freaking out his
eyes are red he's mad at padme padme for
no reason
he chokes her and throws her on the
ground
while she's heavily pregnant with child
i'm like dude why'd you do that
and then he screamed at obi-wan and he's
like you turned her against me
like dude he didn't turn her against you
you turned her against you
and she's not even against you she's
still trying to help you like his
actions just make
no sense i i totally understand that
when it comes to the sith it's about
like
giving in to the emotion
but it's like he just seems
volatile suddenly and i don't
fully understand what's triggering
this volatile nature suddenly but anyway
he throws her on the ground
she dies shortly after that i'm not sure
if we're meant to think that he
contributed to her death
or what but yeah she dies later
but you know we have obi-wan and anakin
they have this
okay i'll just have to say over the top
but
cool looking lightsaber battle on like
a a lava planet that makes no sense
they both should have been burning up
the entire time but whatever it's star
wars i totally get it
um it did look a little silly it was
like kind of going overboard with the
cgi
but the the final climactic moment
which you know even mcgregor is at his
best i think at this moment when he like
looks back and we see the burning
uh limbs cut off corpse almost corpse of
anakin skywalker he looks back at him
and says
he said you were supposed to be the
chosen one you know
yeah you were supposed to you bring
balance to the force and you did the
opposite of that and how could you have
done this
um so more of that should have been in
the movie
more more emphasis on what is happening
because what's happening here is like
er i'm sorry i know i'm going to make
people mad by saying this but this is a
cheap version
of the paul atreides story in dune you
have paula tradies who
starts off with these good intentions
and then you know
devastating things happen because of it
so he goes from protagonist to kind of
an antagonist
so but here we have you know anakin who
starts off this innocent boy he sees
problems within within the jedi
problems which definitely exist
but then also he's manipulated by
palpatine and it's just like
that could have been a much better story
that could have been more solid
if they had really focused on you know
the subtleties of anakin's development
into you know becoming more
of a bad guy i felt like they were kind
of afraid
for most of this movie and for most of
i think the the series to show it and so
when it finally happens and he's
suddenly killing kids it's just
jarring so anyways the rest
i guess is history so we got palpatine
he finds darth vader and he puts him in
the suit and you know anna can become
darth vader and we see darth vader and
padme is dead
but she has given birth to twins and
died in childbirth which is
just like dune but we won't get into
that anyway
they send the kids luke and leia to
different places in the world
i mean in the universe i mean they send
them to different places they're on
different planets
lucas on tatooine uh princess leia is on
that one planet alderaan i remembered it
i didn't even have to look it up
that gets blown up in a new hope so
she's there
and you know they're separated and
they're hiding the twins from
uh the empire the empire they're hiding
the twins from anakin they're hiding the
twins from
palpatine and that is the end of
the second star wars trilogy the prequel
trilogy
all right so this movie like i said was
a lot
easier to get through than those first
two this movie had significant issues
but it is definitely a step
better it is definitely it's a
definitely step in the right direction
but kind of a step in the right
direction too soon
because most of the trilogy is bad even
this movie is not enough to save this
trilogy
even this movie considered the trilogy
itself
is it's it's not there it can't i can't
i can't
reasonably call it a good trilogy i call
this movie
decent this movie is like a c plus this
movie is
competent but did knock my socks off
like i said natalie portman's character
is suddenly changing to be like this
weird damsel
not good uh anakin's son shift
not good still way too much cgi
and it still just overall suffered from
the problems that prequels
often suffer from because you know
nothing is really surprising
if you've seen the original thing all
right so thank you guys so much for
watching i know a lot of you are waiting
on this revenge of the sith review
next i'll be moving into the disney star
wars movies
and i'll do solo and i'll do rogue one
and i'll do force awakens and all the
ones that come after that and it's gonna
be
fun so stay tuned peace out guys
well i think you're completely wrong
clearly the prequels are the superior
films far better than the disney crap
well yeah um thanks for your input you
know in my opinion i think that
i didn't ask that you know in my opinion
phantom menace is the greatest star wars
movie of all time
i should start a youtube channel i'm
gonna start my own youtube channel and
it's gonna be better than this crap uh
whatever dude i'm getting out of here
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
peace out
you